so you're saying you care more about
money than a relationship I don't give a
if she was a homie but if she stole my
money yeah that affects my
[Music]
life men and women cannot just be
friends 3 two one
canot just be friends he's still
deciding but I'll go ahead there's
always this underlying current to a man
a man and a woman when they're just
friends because there's there's this
sexual attraction this energy that you
can't even see it it's always flowing
and men as you know are you guys are
conquerors you want a conquest you want
to even if it's a friend sometimes that
develops into more simply because law of
familiarity you start getting close and
comfortable and maybe you weren't
attracted to her initially but that
opposition of that sexual polarity
always kicks in what if the man is like
not attracted to women just like
generally do you think that's still Oh
you mean if they're if they take a
different like a gay man sexual
orientation woman being friends well I
think that that's different perhaps
because um they're attracted to men so
in that moment they they have taken on
the feminine energy so they only want to
conquer the men not the women well in in
that there's always masculine feminine
energy whether you're man or woman so if
the guy is if the man is gay and
identifies as being attracted to men
then he's in a feminine energy most
now if there's two of them there's one
that's more masculine and more feminine
but that's for another two of my best
friends are women we have great times
together all the time not once have I
considered sleeping with them or
anything like that ever no but that's
the thing is though in their Darkest
Hour in your darkest hour come on no
start CU we started off as friends and
then and I this is like I said I was
never attracted to them a lot of
relation should start like that today
even though I discourage it they say I'm
not attracted to them but it'll grow and
I'm always like yeah it can happen it
can but but the odds of it so I agree
with you on that as well yeah that's why
I'm like I do understand and I get it
but I like two of my best friends are
woman and not once everyone keeps saying
like oh you're going to and I'm like
it's not CU life was a long time are
your friends attractive yes like they
look they look good but attractive is
subjective just just like generally
speaking like your girls like look good
right yes okay though so if you was just
lonely like it's been a moment you
didn't want to beat it you know what I
mean or like you know special exemption
I'm non- monogamous so I never have to
worry about intimacy well that's why so
so you getting you getting played so you
ain't wor about you man he's like
getting it so he doesn't need it but
that's what I'm saying but but but but
but if you was L you wasn't getting it
though and your friend was throwing it
guess that's a different situ that's
what I'm
saying over
here come to the dark side attracted if
we're not attracted it's just friends
friends as a straight very monogamous
man I grew up mainly being friends with
women I felt more comfortable in those
spaces I felt more comfortable talking
to women I've never been like a bro rah
rah that type of thing so I think men
and women absolutely can be I have
friends that I've had since elementary
school middle school we talk very often
and we talk about all these things and
it has never affected that aspect of the
relationship because we're men and women
we're just people and people can be
friends it's not completely agree yeah
so my perspective is from kind of a
Christian worldview um I believe that
you know God created man and woman to
come together in love and attraction to
be one um and so from that standpoint I
believe that there is just a natural
attraction I have had some extremely
close friends that were girls and that
attraction just developed cuz it wasn't
just physical but it was love it was
getting to see how they were around
their family around kids what they do
for work what they do for school
developing that relationship so from my
perspective that attraction develops
because I wasn't just looking at her
from just you know she's just a body
yeah she just a piece of meat you
develop that emotional attraction emal
which is why I'm over here yes joining
the dark I would ask because I
completely agree with you on that from
the same Christian standpoint 100% wait
hold up have you been sleeping all right
I haven't which is why I'm so glad that
I found Nero if you haven't heard of
Nero they're known for their energy and
focused functional gum and mints that
give you a balanced boost of energy and
enhanced focus and I'm here to share
that their newest edition the sleep and
recharge melway mint is launching on
January 8th they're made with your
favorite cozy sleep time AIDS like
melatonin chamomile Elderberry and more
to help you fall
asleep stay asleep and wake up feeling
refreshed also did you know that your
regular melatonin gummies use a heat
process to manufacture their products
that results in the breakdown of
melatonin resulting in them adding more
melatonin than the intended dose but
Nero uses a patented cold compression
process to give you the exact amount of
melatonin needed plus narrow sleep is
sugar-free naturally sweetened
gluten-free and vegan friendly these new
mints come in two different shrinks mix
Berry which has 1 mg of melatonin and
nightberry with 5 mg of melatonin and
both launched on Monday January 8th be
sure to click the link in the
description and visit nero.com and check
out Nero's sleep and recharge melway
mints and their energy and focus gments
and use code Jubilee at checkout for 20%
off your first subscription purchase
thanks so much to Nero for sponsoring
this episode and now let's get back to
it I would date someone I do not find
physically attractive oh 3 2
1 ah man uh like you want to say
something
first uh I do it all the time because
there is a
there's a lot you don't just from the
physicalness it's like sometimes uh
there's some people that I learn just by
like just by not going in based on
physical attraction is I end up being
attracted to them just because of their
personality and you know looks can be
deceiving I could say the same on the
opposite end where I thought someone was
absolutely attractive but then I got to
know them and they were the worst person
I could have possibly been on a date
with I feel like like you can definitely
not be attracted to somebody initially
and then as you get but I feel like at
that point like once I like someone's
personality romantically I probably also
think they're attractive I would say
that for some you know it's not a
reflection on your character how
weighted appearance versus personality
might be a difference from person to
person I think that we have our
preferences and I think that a certain
element of uh physical attractiveness is
fitness health hygiene and that reflects
on usually competence responsibility and
dedication but um I do see it as
important although not a uh the whole
package by any means right it is it's
the very first impression you get of
most people yes cuz like you meet
someone and you can't hear their voice
first thing most of the time you just
see them and you're like oh that
person's attractive or like I don't see
myself with that person because I don't
find them attractive and that's totally
fine not everybody's attracted to
everybody but me personally I would not
be with someone I don't find attractive
so great so I got to give context here
right if I'm meeting you in person and
you don't look good then I'm over there
with y'all but if I'm meeting you
through a dating nap and I get catfished
but you're kind of
cool then then cuz cuz I met a girl they
had nice pictures but then when I seen
her in person she was a little bit
bigger than I prefer right and there's
nothing wrong with that right well
everyone can have nice pictures
today now there's nothing wrong with
being a big bigger but for preference
sake I wasn't really feeling it but her
personality is what got me and then I
started entertaining it so right even
though I got catfish I actually
considered you know taking it seriously
and I also date like sometimes I really
try this cuz it's led to some great
people I've got to meet along the way I
will date outside of my preferences just
to see what that's like if you're not
initially attracted to that person and
have a strong sexual attraction then
it's not going to work because we know
that relationships get worse not better
that's like I don't know I think it's a
recipe for a disaster cheating is the
worst thing my partner could do to me
3 two
one I feel like there's like probably
worse things like in theory that a
partner could do to their partner but
just because that's such an important
aspect for me and like I feel like my
partners in the past have like been very
aware that that was like something that
I actively would not do I feel like that
would just make that adds like an extra
element of evil yeah I mean my mind goes
to marriage I mean you know when you
marry this woman when I marry woman
someday you promise literally everything
you have to be with her literally thick
and thin to be with her through
everything through highs and lows and I
mean if you do something like cheating
it's basically like screw this love this
wasn't real these promises that I made
between us and God me nothing I think
for a lot of Christians that's like a
big thing is cheating I mean 100% And
it's it's one of the Ten Commandments
too it's like do not commit adultery so
in my that is definitely the worst thing
because getting married is a promise
between you and that person and God I
mean technically there's worse things
like they could kill you which would
probably be the worst thing cuz then
like you're not even in the picture you
belong over here but I I'm kind of like
you know but um I would say that would
like destroy me and I would never even
think about something like that yeah I
100% agree I was actually cheated on a
few like four or five months ago I
struggled with self-esteem so much
growing up and that was the worst thing
that could have happened that destroyed
any chance I had at self Lov at that
time and it was it was just devastating
for me like it really was just
devastating cuz it didn't just destroy
that relationship it destroyed my entire
image of myself that I had built up
based on other people's validation and I
had to rip it down to the studs and just
fully start over yeah so that's why I'm
over here strong L agree for me
personally it was the worst thing that
could have happened cheating ised up
it's not a good feeling is it the worst
thing that a partner could do to me to
be honest I've outgrown that bro I had
over A4 million dollars stolen from me
this year bro and that put me in a dark
ass place now imagine if my partner
stole that money from me or she was just
a homie I'd be more mad about the money
you right I don't have that money to be
stolen so you're saying you care you
care more about money than a
relationship well because at the end of
the day me and my ex we ain't together
no more so I don't give a if she was a
homie if she was right but if she stole
my money yeah that affect my life you
know mean right so so my whole thing is
when we talking about the promp is
cheating the worst scene of the part
that could do for me I've been cheating
on before the first time the first time
I was cheating on bro I was petty I was
in high school bro I drove all the way
to the crib and told her mom what she
was doing with me you know what I mean
right yeah I was I was vengeful but now
I just be like you know so many people
do it there's worse things that they
happen like if you kill my mom I'll be
more mad rather than youing a homie the
sanctity of marriage is supposed to be
till death do its part that doesn't mean
if your carnal flesh gave in and you had
uh you know an indiscretion that you're
able to hit the door running no that
means there's work to be done we have
problems for me I think it actually can
be the best thing because it it's a sign
that there is a huge problem in the
relationship that needs fixed most sex
is not emotional so it's just a bodily
act that animals do and you're going to
to blow up a marriage or a relationship
a relationship with children over sex to
me I think that is
ridiculous you could say that about the
person doing the cheating too I've been
cheated on so I have been cheated on
well so so you think that's something
you could like oh you have gotten over
it I have gotten over it if my husband
cheats on me of course I'd be devastated
I'm human I believe just like all y'all
too but I'd be like damn like what's the
problem here what's the issue and can we
solve this why don't you just talk like
you guys are married and you have that
emot happen though we know that people
don't I think we should work to changing
that we should but that doesn't mean I'm
going to Unconditionally Love You just
because you went and had an indiscretion
I wouldn't do that to my son my son FS
up all the time and does crazy I'm
like where on God's green earth did you
learn that that doesn't mean I Stopped
Loving Him for men I feel like we take
cheating a lot more personally as
opposed to women it comes to the ego
people's boundaries are all different so
if you know you have perhaps been with
no or less partners and then you get
married to learn that that person
cheated would be proportionally much
more devastating to someone who's had
maybe a lot of relationship experience
and therefore that's more of an active
part in their life so I think that
everyone's boundaries are different so
for some people I have seen them get
over it I know for me personally I would
say that I I'm a woman that would take
that devastatingly seriously and would
not look lightly at it so it depends on
the person's boundaries if you had
children and if you had a family
involved you would break up your family
over a man's one time IND
yes that would adversely affect your
child and possibly send her to the
stripper pool I don't feel comfortable I
don't feel comfortable answering that
question because I feel like it's making
a lot of what happens this what happens
we don't want to questions but that
shows an example onto the kids like oh
this is not that bad of a thing yeah and
I also I think that like somebody
cheating on you is more than just like a
physical thing like that's a break of
trust and I feel like if you can't if
you can't have that trust in someone
then I also don't want them to be like
raising my kids with me so we're all
saying that love is conditional is the
end of
100% monogamy is
overrated 3 2
one monogamy is
overrated sorry of
[Laughter]
course um come on man get over here get
your butt over here you know you belong
at
least we're like seconds think about it
we're taught from the Disney all these
fairy tales it's like you're supposed to
be with that one and only you know so
it's very frightening to break something
traditional but after like a few months
with it I just knew I'm like this is the
right choice I've been in the most
happiest of relationships I just
celebrated my three years with my
primary partner we and like um as well
as my 2-year anniversary with with my
secondary partner but it's like uh you
know I I do think that monogamy is kind
of overrated I don't think that um
there's anything like you know wrong
with it if that's what you want to do go
for it but I do think that uh non-
monogamy and poly relationship should be
something that like it's looked at as an
option I think nowadays I know more open
relationships than I do strictly close
relationships with the people that I
know um I would say I disagree that
monogamy is overrated but I do agree
that for some people like yourself poly
relationships work better so I don't
look down upon them I think whatever
works for you works for you
but
that like people that are similarly just
very focused and have strict kind of
like I I just can't ever oh my God I
could never imagine more than like one
person a it depends person so therefore
I don't think monogamy is overrated I
think it depends on the person and I
think for me it's definitely not over
it's the only option for you paully is
like the right way so it just depends
I'm completely non-judgmental I think it
just I I I I I just want to say I don't
mind monogamy right right I just don't
like a controlling relationship where
it's completely like no you can't nobody
else but at the same time you want to me
once or twice a month you know what me
right right exct yeah so so so you know
me and my ex was together for 5 years I
actually broke up with her in April but
for 2 and A2 years out that relationship
we was barely for like maybe once a
months then I moved during the crib and
then when I moved her in the house for
the whole first year of her living in
the house she just didn't want to have
sex and now had an agreement that we had
agreed on where we could do various
things that we just didn't want to know
about and stuff like that right and
because you wasn't me and like that I
was handling the agreement like I was
following the agreement but because
there were certain things that wasn't
necessarily 100% out there that created
complications in the relationship to the
point that didn't ended up well as
breaking up I think it's definitely like
it has a place like for certain people
like obviously we have two people who
are like very religious here and it it
works well for them and I just think
like if I was at an open relationship I
would go crazy like even when I'm in
like a normal relationship where it's
like I don't expect them to cheat on me
I'm so like like
gu yeah so I just like if that was if
like I just I can't imagine a world
where I would agree with that and also
before I had like Loved Someone or like
dated anybody I was like oh no I could
totally even in an open relationship and
then I actually did and I was like are
you very sexual person just curious
though like kind of kind of sure she's
like yeah so so if your partner was very
sexual too and he's like baby like I
want to be with you but you always just
shutting him down cuz you ain't in the
mood I don't that's like never happened
I'm say like not that's like personally
for me not an issue but also I don't
know I think that would definitely be a
conversation if there was like an
imbalance but also I think there's
different things that make people
compatible as partners and that's
definitely one of them what he's saying
is the Cry of many men today is that
they're not getting enough sex from
their partner and not just sex it's not
like men are like oh I'm heartless
connection but for listen men need sex
to create intimacy women need intimacy
to have sex and people get married and
then around it's like just don't
get married then and stay stay like this
boy date dates and anniversaries every
my people
God next month this is one year
anniversary with partner number three
like just you know what I mean just be
out there doing your dates and does that
make sense by the end of the day nobody
should dictate your relationship because
everyone's going to try to push what
they think works for you know this is
what's best for you like I'm over it I'm
like why so I can be frustrated and this
off and like I've tried it to me it does
it did not work I want to take
perspective cuz you know Christian I'm
going to take perspective that's a
little away from from my biblical views
and no disrespect but I do think
polygamy is just laziness not this is
polyamory poly polygamy is when it's
multiple just one person um I see that
as laziness that you don't want to
commit to someone in the hard times like
you were talking about a little bit
about well they're not getting fulfilled
sexually so why not find it somewhere
else why not just do the hard work to
work on your relationship I was ready
for this question and I mean there's
there's such a emotional there's a psych
psychological just importance in being
with one person um I mean bonding so
then why do we have such a high divorce
rate I agree with you on that why do we
have such a high divorce why why why are
people still cheating why is open
because they're not cuz our country I
think is lazy we don't want to have
these hard conversations
maybe we should go to therapy maybe we
should try to get because we love one
another it's
like talk it to talk about so so me and
my ex we actually did couples therapy
cuz again we was barely for like two and
a half years bro we went to couples
therapy next thing you know everything
was great for like a month and then one
day she just blew up she said man I
still don't feel like you this this and
that like she went in bro you know what
I mean so at the same time I there was a
point in my relationship where it really
just came to the point like baby I I
love everything everything else about
you you know what I mean right this area
of sex are you still attracted to me she
say yes I'm still attracted to you right
well here's the thing if you just don't
want to have sex with me right go some
other dudes I don't give a let's have
that conversation right cuz I get
everything else I want from you anyways
I was open to the idea I didn't I want
to be with my woman but if you don't
want to do this I'm fine just yeah the
same I mean I understand the importance
of sex but there's some self there's
self-sacrifice in every relationship you
need to make if if you're happy with her
and everything she had but you also have
a value on sex then maybe she's not the
right person but the thing was did I
want to go look for greener grass or did
I just want to water my own grass I I
stuck it out for 5 Years bro that's
another aspect of being like
romantically compatible with someone and
sometimes there's like one thing that's
not there and that sucks but it's like
if that especially if that other person
that's something that they prioritize
like personally if my partner was like
oh like I love like everything about you
but like this is not compatible and they
wanted to go to sleep with other people
like that make me feel so bad about
myself and that's why you do it works
for you that's I'm saying like that's
that's like compatibility issue then I
think because I like I don't I'm not
your ex-girlfriend I don't know how she
feels but if I were in that scenario I
just like that just would make me so sad
even though it's like it's not of your
fault that that the comments going to
talk so much right right the day I
broke up with my girl bro she told me
like she told me a lot I want to say
everything the day I broke up with my
girl she said man she's like uh I just
be counting down the days like we had
sex in like 12 days I got to go have sex
with now actually going to get mad you
know mean right and I'm hearing all this
and right you know what I mean so she
said a bunch and I feel like I had to
break up with her right did not want to
I feel like I had to definitely take a
to on you that's a I think all this goes
back to clear communication because if
if um I don't think that cheating means
that polyamory would actually be the
solution to that I think that it goes
back to your values and works for you
and I think that I I would maybe venture
to say that more people might be poly
than you know are exploring that right
now um and still at the same time
monogamy I think works for a lot of
people so it's all what works for you I
would date someone in this room three
two
one what I don't know these
people surprised he was over here I'm
like what are you doing I
know the energy is cool you just have to
have a pulse and we'll go out with you
that's not that's not how that is like
like like like like like per perfect
example right like like know she got
good energy right now IM J might be the
coolest person next thing you know you
start getting Anor she might be crazy be
like then you come over here all of a
sudden generally the few people have
been attracted to they don't they look
like Tim Burton dolls or just like weird
goth people yeah just like weird goth
people so like I it's just coinc it's
very rare that I see these people so
it's not a personal thing sir my
girlfriend would kill me and respect I
like to think I'm pretty picky so but am
am am I not your type
you got me feeling some type of way now
that you say it I don't know so you're
my good oh oh okay
okay oh my gosh um I mean for me beliefs
beliefs are extremely important um she's
blushing I mean I a trying to get all
flirty but you are also very
gorgeous please send us wedding
invitation but no beliefs are very
important Within relationships I think I
look into obviously I have a desire to
be a husband and one day be a father and
I think if you have different different
and beliefs it's very hard to raise
coherently absolutely um I think that
just is extremely
[Applause]
important
you
good you're an
amazing amazing I
guess you're hilarious
don't